hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the surface topography of
silicone breast implants mediates the
foreign body response in mice rabbits
and humans
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
joshua doloff assistant professor
biomedical engineering and materials
science engineering
at the johns hopkins university in
baltimore maryland
dr doloff you may now begin your
presentation
first i just want to say a quick thank
you to the thermo organizers of this
webinar for the invitation to speak
really appreciate the thought
um my name is joshua doloff i'm an
assistant professor in biomedical and
materials science engineering at johns
hopkins university i'm going to be
speaking today about the surface
topography of silicone breast implants
mediates the foreign body response in
mice rabbits and humans
just to start you off um
you may be familiar with the ability of
immune cells to phagocytose eat up and
clear small nanoparticulates
however when objects
larger macro scale devices such as
stents electrode arrays
pacemakers large volumetric material
inserts for bone or cartilage repair
glucose monitors and so on um exceed the
size of a single cell they're physically
too large to be extruded and cleared
from the body
and so as a consequence the body turns
to do the next best thing that they can
which is essentially
seal the device behind a dense layer of
scar tissue and we call this process
fibrosis when i first joined the lab in
my postdoc back at mit uh i asked um
bought my mentor bob basically is this
some sort of sort of plastic sheath you
put over the device and he chuckled at
first and said no and in the next image
he showed me
uh which wasn't in his initial talk
which is why i went up to an ass about
this after the fact um he said it here
is the actual capsule and if you take a
look at this there's a much more phlegm
or white blood cell laden infiltration
appearance to it so when you cough up
flame when you're sick it has sort of a
yellowish to white appearance a lot of
this is dense extracellular matrix we
can see this with a histology standing
and see a thick capsule that forms
these
devices that are about the size of a usb
key
and they actually were in humans for
over six months published back as i was
under the lab
uh they received a wireless signal it
sends an electrical impulse to melt off
a gold nano cover on a nano weld it
releases reservoir after reservoir of
a drug and in this particular case it
was a small molecule for uh treating
osteoporosis
um eventually over time i'll also
mention you don't see much immunologic
activity here but after six months we
now know even beyond three months as the
capsule develops um extensively the
immune system sort of goes away because
it no longer really sees the surface of
the device it needs to respond
and
so that we i'll show that in some of the
data that i'm going to present today too
all right to better understand
um where does fibrosis even come from it
is a defense-based mechanism in the body
that obviously is not just relevant to
biomedical devices which have only
existed for the past maybe one to two
hundred years
you go back far enough and you have
metal shrapnel lead bullets bronze
copper from from various areas of human
history but even then that's not long
enough for evolutionary time scales
uh only when you really go back to our
paleolithic forebears with stone bone
and even tooth fragments
wood splinters and even larger pieces of
dirt
do you also realize that they too get
fibrosis when they enter in the body
when they're not supposed to be
another confounding variable in the
field of fibrosis also was
the the lack of understanding
surrounding what anal models are
translationally relevant to a human
um as an example biopsy and mice on the
left here is very compliant not not that
fibrotic
actually they're really good they're th2
immune skewed really great for
antibody titers for cancer vaccine
trials
also notice that some strains of rats
were a little bit more compliant in
fibrous much
and then early on in our in
my postdoc work we had a meeting with a
specialist from biogenitic
and they told us everyone in the field
recognizes that the c-57 black six mouse
is the quote-unquote pro-fibrotic model
that everybody needs to think about at
least at the rodent level
and then over years from working with
pigs uh you know many pigs yorkshires
large white and so on we realize
they have an intact fibrotic response so
do new zealand white rabbits uh various
monkey species in this particular case
we uh i'll show data later on
settlemongos monkeys
and then obviously relevance to humans
too
and so just to show you this quickly so
here's an example of these
clear translucent hydrogel spheres that
we place in these animals
uh just off from the start you can see
the black six mice all of them are very
apparent visually they're individually
all fibros that this white yellowish
appearance again is immune cell
aggregation and uh extracellular matrix
deposition adhesion on the surface
in biopsy mice by comparison very few
show fibrosis most of them are still
clear and translucent the same volume
though is in the field of view and in
lewis rats you see even less fibrosis
maybe some fur debris from just
dissection of the animal
um in the monkeys not only do you see
fibrosis
you actually have extensive embedding of
the materials into spreading tissue to
do this is what we also see in the black
six mice and time
usually happens with
non-collagen capsule encapsulated
uh fat pads as opposed to you know lobes
of the liver kidney spleen and so on
even when the capsule touches and even
gets pushed in and embedded we've even
plucked out capsules from lobes to the
liver before
they're not prominently fibrous and the
reason for this is because the collagen
capsule segregates the main organ except
for the fat the fat fat in your body
does not have collagen wrapping around
the outside of it the same way that
primary organs do and they are highly
vessel-laden so they are trafficking
highways for the immune system to come
through
and to move out into surrounding tissues
when there's a stimulus and so an
example of this
is that um
you know in this case it could be tumor
cell that gets damaged or a biomaterial
that's a braided implanted in the site
it may be rubbing or braiding against
surrounding tissue or cells and so
there's stress or inflammatory cytokines
that are released and immune cells have
the capacity for sensing these signals
and moving up
the low end of the gradient all the way
up to the high concentration range of
this gradient
you know we ran a approximately a 30
merplex luminex assay looking at many
different potential cytokines in uh
global circulation so it would be easy
for clinicians obviously to be able to
have a test where they could just bleed
animals or take blood from people and um
and maybe tell from just that alone is
your device implant system failing well
of approximately 30 factors only four
increase and we only saw significant
increases in one day day one one day
following implantation
when you follow up with each of these
molecules they all went back to baseline
within the next three to four days
indicating that they rather than seeing
this long-term buildup which is what we
usually see locally around the implant
uh we associate this instead with a day
zero
surgery event which then dissipates over
time
now this material system is really nice
it's actually translucent to start uh
it's the same hydrogels are found in you
know food products such as boba tea the
bubbles and tapioca the tapioca bubbles
excuse me in tea and bubble tea um you
have fake raw or sushi in in uh so like
the little orange fish eggs which aren't
always real because they're expensive
they could just be little hydrogel
um
spheres with a food and coloring
additives to them so
and if you ever run a dna or aggro a dna
aggressor or a polychromy western
blotting gel it's the same sort of same
sort of material class um bin and john
because of its translucent nature you
can see when it's nonfibrosidal
completely clean partially more
completely fully fibrous uh and even
when that fibrotic plaque starts to grow
out outward and starts to attach to
other surrounding either materials and
they clump together or to fat in nearby
tissue
uh when i joined the lab it also wasn't
appreciated very much in terms of well
is this all extracellular matrix this is
all proteinaceous material or other
living cells on the surface of these
materials too
and so we started the lab and the
members of the lab started doing nuclear
dappy staining and saying oh yeah there
are in fact living cells right at the
surface
um
which we grew to appreciate and to
understand that they were actually
immune cells and so here you can see
cd68 positive macrophages cd19 positive
b cells alpha small muscle actin is a
surrogate marker for fibrosis it's
expressed by
smooth muscle uh sorry fibroblasts
activated
myelomyofibroblasts that come in and
deposit are heavily involved in
depositing collagen matrix we also see
ly6g positive neutrophils
and
and so canonically the view of
biomaterial response was protein
such as complement or coagulation
factors clotting factors and antibodies
in green oxidization of of the material
surface or binding of protein to the
meal material surface would make it
readily visible and apparent to the
immune system that it was not part of
self
and uh precipitate sort of this fibrotic
cascade
originally it was thought that
neutrophils precede
um macrophages monocytes macrophages
are they mature from
uh their progenitor cell macrophage
monocytes excuse me are immature form
that circulated in blood
so when macrophages move out of those
blood vessels into the strutting tissue
or the surrounding tissue site where the
implant resides
not only do they um hit a more mature
phenotype they also eventually will fuse
together to cover the whole surface of
the device and they form what's called
foreign body giant cells
in the cascade of monocyte macrophage to
form body giant cell
fusion you also have recruitment of
fibrobla fibroblasts in the background
and then layering a vector cell and
matrix
in that time
um
in my postdoc i sort of i realized that
there are many different tool sets
specifically in the background for c57
black six the strain itself we have
individual point mutations that knock
out for instance individual immune cells
t and b cells alone both combinatorially
and so on and so forth
and even though there were some effects
when you remove b cells which i i i'm
you know we attribute to
them secreting cytokines that further
potentiate macrophage activity that
drive fibrosis
it doesn't get rid of fibrosis
completely so we instead focused on for
instance macrophage dysfunction
macrophage depletion uh even inhibition
or polarization with small molecules we
found many
instances where we could eliminate
fibrosis completely in that regard
and so there's con this notion by the
way that neutrophils have to precede
monocytes macrophages is in this model
incorrect so
um
even biochromatic studies have recently
shown with implant response that they
actually are there within the first both
are there within the first few hours
and their kinetics are very similar
and actually so functionally
when you deplete neutrophils you
actually see that not only these
fibrosis is still there therefore it's
not required for fibrosis to occur
fibrosis got more became more aggressive
materials clumped even faster which
doesn't happen usually two weeks post
implantation in the wild type case it
usually only happens maybe
four
plus weeks out
um and we attribute this to neutrophils
having a subtype of cell called
myelodirect suppressor cell that when
you eliminate it it removes a negative
feedback check
on the immune system and the immune
system
uh overreacts and it attacks even faster
but only when you in particular when you
lose macrophages and in combination with
neutrophils do you lose fibrosis
altogether
what was also interesting is i
implicated b cells before just briefly
but when you deplete macrophages
b cells in these last two cases never
show up they're gone as well so
macrophages we understand
secret effect they say create chemokine
which we identified as cxl13 they it
leads to the later recruitment
downstream accommodative d cells which
then show up
they don't secrete antibody actually
they uh we again secrete cytokines
locally right in the fibrotic plaque as
i showed you and they
basically bring the level of fibrosis
around one week at 50
by two weeks it's up to about 90
95 percent
material coverage
if you deplete mac b cells it's stuck at
that sort of 50 percent level even later
two weeks
all right one of the cool things over
time i learned this from my tumor
immunology days in my phd i learned how
to use a gentlemax dissociator
instrument to dissociate tumors
associated with organs also then later
adapted this technique for biomaterials
and being able to dissociate and remove
cells off the cells off the surface and
then actually obtain a viable single
cell suspension
this could be used originally in the
context of tumors but also here in
biomaterial cases
uh for looking at cellular response at
the therapeutic side of interest and so
in this case this is my very first uh 4a
in flow cytometry this is old school two
laser based facts caliber
and uh
gotta respect the old crt monitor too
but you that we essentially would use
fluorophores strictly usually in the
green or the red or near infrared range
just to avoid compensation issues and i
usually kept it at two color systems
in addition with the association you can
see here uh the dissociation technique
that we used that i used and developed
removes 99 of the cells maybe 95 or so
90 plus i guess conservatively see a
little bit of remaining on some capsules
but the capsules are intact we actually
get most of the cells immunological
response off the surface
and then we can stain them with
different antibodies back back then
given that we were only trying to stick
with red and green
um
you know i had to i had to allocate
individual samples into multiple tubes
with only two antibodies in each very
limited ability to do multi-color panels
and so in the top case it was c11b and
c68 for macrophage response and you can
see day one day four seven fourteen and
twenty eight increased over time
macrophages were in fact the largest
dynamic responder neutrophils
increased also at day one and then
plateaued and even decreased at least
macrophage compositionally macrophages
compositionally took over and then b
cells showed up more prominently in a
delayed fashion at day seven which is
why i thought they were acting in an
adaptive capacity but again they don't
produce antibody here
um
and uh
and they end up directly in the plaque
so they're doing something directly
functional
in terms of um and so we did all that
work in mice which is really nice
there's a lot of immunologic tool sets
and then we we expanded this work to
sonoma gas monkeys
uh testing translation of this fibrotic
um phenomena that we were seeing and so
in in larger animals like monkeys and
humans and us and human in humans as
well there is a sack of fat literally a
tube of fat and highly vascularized fat
called the momentum that wraps around
the entire gi tract and you can see that
here
more clearly the day 28 sample so the
lobes of the liver would be at the
bottom of the image
here is the very bottom of the abdomen
which is called the douglas space at day
zero we have one port for the
laparoscope to take photos another port
to put flush in capsules or to later
retrieve them at different time points
and you can see all of them are easily
visible day zero and by day 28 they're
still visible but they're
almost it almost looks as though they're
sinking into the tissue
and histologically when we look
again using hd masons trichrome
um we see mostly fat and blood vessels
the natural natural tissue here at day
zero
and also later at day 28 with just a
mock implant where we inject saline or
pbs so no material is present when there
is a foreign biomaterial it gets
literally
grabbed by
immune cells and fibroblasts secrete
collagen this dense blue
around individual capsules that they
literally get embedded and almost sink
into the tissue
furthermore when we do immunofluorescent
staining you can see cb68 here
macrophages in green we also have alpha
smooth muscle actin
showing fibroblasts and fibrosis markers
of response in the monkeys as well um
one of the cool things is a comparison
here between mock and implanted for the
black six mice showing macrophages in
red and neutrophils and blue we i was
also able to we could pinch away part of
the momentum take a a piece of fat and
tie hilarious suture around it so the
animals wouldn't obviously
bleed out um but we
you know dissociated those tissues or
even isolated individually free capsules
and dissociated the cells off the
surface and also showed a very similar
kinetic scale of response with
macrophages and neutrophils as well
further we did gene expression analysis
to show many of uh immune markers in
these models cd68 macrophages in both
the subcutaneous space as well as in the
intraperitoneal abdomen um
ly6g neutrophil marker does not exist in
monkeys or humans so we use cd66b which
is here
and lastly we also identified
in rodents as well as confirming monkeys
the relevancy of colony ceiling factor
one receptor and uh being able to
inhibit it to block fibrosis in these
models
so lo and behold over the over years my
postdoc and since then we have this
pipeline of
testing material design
automating in some cases chemistry or
testing physiochemical properties
testing the ability for materials to
actually form and cross-link and then to
also look at fabrication techniques to
get uniform reproducible architecture
and shape because we also know that
those mechanical features do affect host
response as well
you can place these materials
subcutaneously and do a whole body
imaging for inflammation
we also can place these in with with
graphs like such as islets for type of
diabetes in more of a functional
scenario in diabetic mice and then i
know i showed you the the monkey model
data but we've also we also have a
manuscript in consideration uh where
we've actually you know monkeys can be
prohibitive
where you actually take a human human
immune system and put it into a mouse
and a humanized model and we finally
obtained one after multiple attempts
that actually shows fibrosis
all right so moving forward
i just want to talk about um
shift tack a little bit and talk about
breast implant implants as the title
implied and so just before i start i
just wanted to say that we were at the
lab at mit establishment labs
motiva came to bob and started asking
about some material responses they were
seeing and so bob brought some of us in
on the project initiates consultants
just to give our feedback because we
were sort of the local about
compatibility experts at the time and
and so over time it became apparent
especially as discussions
developed that we actually wanted to do
some investigation investigational work
and not just to straight consulting and
so eventually we we stopped being
consultants
and we started pursuing more of an
academic project which we recently
published in nature biomedical
engineering this year
and specifically it rates the breast
implants and the problems associated
with them and so i've already shown you
guys the concepts of fibrosis and
formation of a big scar tissue wall
around the outside well in the breast
implant world they call that a capsule
so you get a thick capsule that forms
over implants and they can even
individual strains of fibrous tissue are
weak but many together
um
gain incredible tensile strength
and you actually have a process called
contracture that occurs
which is literally squeezing of the
device
and and and in the case of a metal
implant like the microchip device it
won't distort but for soft polymer
implants silicone implants like breast
implants they will get become misshapen
you can even see ripple or tension lines
through the skin
and so there are different
surface
architectures that have been studied
over the years traditional
control smooth
is about a 20 percent failure rate
within about 10 years of implantation
um still tech's mentor uh
within eight years maybe about 11
percent or so buy a cell had also around
a 20 percent failure rate after 10 years
and then interestingly motifs assumption
labs had these two surfaces smooth silk
and velvet surface
that had like a point zero one percent
or something statistically it was no no
different than zero really within the
first five six years and i think they
have data hours of 10 plus years now
and so trying to break this down and
understand what was happening here
because in order to really appreciate
the technology you want to know how it
works right so
um in order to standardize breast
implantation in comparisons across
different different technologies the fda
released the standard an iso document in
2018
clarifying that they describe
quote unquote smooth implants as
anything with a surface roughness below
10 microns and so when you look at the
roughness of these commercially
available implants the traditional
smooth which i'll show you scanning
electron microscopy of the surface on
shortly is basically very close to zero
smooth silk surfaces around three or
four micron average roughness velvet
surface around 15
celtex
around 30 or 32 microcell and biocell
so micro texture here is anything above
10 but below 50 and macro textured is
anything above 50 where these two fall
into that category
so in addition to surface roughness the
mechanical properties such as loading
and stress and strain deformation uh
hydrophobicity something that affects
beating up of water so what ability
surface chemistry like if you do you
change the chemistry of the material or
not
but really what we're going to focus on
today is we're going to show you that
the chemistry is the same across these
materials on the outside shell of the
implant and we're going to instead focus
just on surface roughness alone because
obviously there was a very good
understanding where we measured these
these values but there we started to try
to figure out this tighter surface
topography how does it affect host
response about compatibility
so historic united states the vast
majority of implants have been smooth
surface the the higher texturing became
very prominent in other countries
outside in south america brazil europe
asia and uh it relates to well technical
plants stick in place they actually
literally help hold in place a little
bit better but they also theorized that
it would improve biocompatibility and
reduce scarring
well we saw some of the earlier fair
rates and that in some cases maybe is
sort of true but in other cases not so
much
so we first wanted to just understand
well how do these actually differ at the
physical and chemical levels so
human-sized implants we actually got
commercial implants
took the shells from these implants and
imaged them and scanning electron
microscopy so here's traditional smooth
here's smooth silk again average
roughness of four microns very small
contact points but still considered in
that smooth category
velvet celtex velvet um and siltex again
i think in this case they both fall into
micro texture then buy a cell falls into
macro texture and so how are these how
are these produced well we worked with
uh material science team establishment
labs to then miniaturize variants of
these implant types and so we got to so
the first three were produced with a
mold literally you create a mold you
flow silicone over it you flip it inside
out and basically there's your surface
so here's smooth here's
smooth silk like and velvet-like similar
average roughnesses
celtx is actually produced by a
different manufacturing method as is
biocell sultex is produced by taking a
polyurethane foam and literally dabbing
it into wet silicone and getting sort of
a texture a textured surface from that
saw the biocell is produced by salt loss
you see these big cubic-like structures
because they literally will take wet
silicone dunk it into salt
flow uh don't dunk another don't get one
more time into silicone get another thin
layer on top and then submerge the
implant the salt dissolves and diffuses
through the upper layer and then they
take a brush and scratch open these sort
of big open cavities that look kind of
cubic and salt like in shape
and so we also
utilize a technique called non-contact
profilometry which doesn't just look at
visual topography it also looks at
quantifying the level of
how high do the peaks
rise above the average plateau and then
how low do the valleys fall and in
addition it also can give you a really
good sense of how dense or how sparsely
far apart are the individual contact
points that potentially immune cells
might grab onto and so we see
reasonably good comparison between the
human size implants and then the
miniaturized implants which we'll show
you later in the mice
in terms of the numbers that we received
from quantifying individual units and
shells from different units again we it
was close to zero for this the
traditional smooth 4 microns 15 28 50
and 83 for the human scale implants and
then for the mini implants we didn't we
didn't get truly one that fully
recapitulated the average close to the
microcell implant but most of the others
are reasonably well
represented 0 4 and 15 are identical
here for the first three
uh polyurethane foam is close it's
around 30 and salt loss technique at 90
is closer to 83 for the human scale
and then we also elicited um
so showing that surface topography is
similar we we also elicited a used
utilized technique called
xps or x-ray photoelectron spectroscopy
showing that the chemistry in the shell
the chemicals and the elements in the
shell of the implant are similar to we
looked at carbon oxygen silicone which
obviously makes sense and then platinum
is used as the catalyst and
cross-linking of silicone
and it's toxic to living systems you can
see not determined thankfully in all
cases across the commercial as well as
the miniaturized mouse implant and
pretty good consistency
in each of these elemental levels no
significant differences popped out
all right so we started in the
human scale case we actually had a
visiting surgeon show us this insertion
technique shaven sterilized the the
surgery field puts all drape we
scrubbed in used sterile gloves we
dropped a sterile implant out of a
sterile package directly from you know
vendor materials and we used what is
called an insertion sleeve it actually
almost looks like a little funnel that
you would put icing on a cake
and what it allows you to do is apply
back pressure you twist and push the
implant out through a very small opening
a very small opening at the end of the
cone uh which allows you to get distort
the implant very temporarily but it
allows you to get a very big implant
into a very small incision line this is
uh incredible and i when i saw for the
first time it amazed me
and so we we obviously have we
place the implant over to the side away
from the incision line again so they're
not overlapping we don't have to worry
about confounding like when we look at
response what was it to do to the injury
of the incision or is it due to just the
implant material presence and then the
rabbits recovered quite nicely we
monitored them for
however long we wanted to just to show
you uh what contracture looks like the
control smooth implants even as early as
three weeks showed contracture so you
can see the ripple lines here and
pinching the skin they shift around a
bit it it's almost like it's like
they're kinked or crinkled almost like
crinkled plastic
in the case of smooth silk
very supple response the four micron
surface
did not have the same appearance after
the same time point
um and so this contracture lines and
ripple lines happen in human patients
too and obviously cause problems not
only with um
implant response but also irritation and
discomfort to the patient
so it's a lot of work summarizing just
one slide but basically we see a three
and three weeks and it's six months the
fibrotic
thickening here uh so you see this red
dotted line so to the right is the
fibrotic layer you can see it in dense
blue newly formed collagen and mason's
trichrone
as opposed to this smooth slope form
micron surface very thin very controlled
and you can see the quantitation of this
from at three weeks
on top of the implant as well as the
bottom of the implant you can see
control smooth down to silk surface a
little bit upward velvet and then for
the three
uh so one of the micro textures celtex
and the two macro textured actually form
what we see what paper clinicians see
clinically in human patients so doctors
see this quite often what they call a
double capsule formation so instead of a
single ring a fibrotic layer there's an
outer capsule so there's a red line and
then another orange line here pale
orange line and then there's a darker
kind of pink or purple zone where
there's a harder inner capsule that
forms and it almost fills in the actual
topography of the surface of the implant
in the case of the most macro textured
biases you can almost see
lines that move back and forth as you're
seeing the texture basically being
mirrored in that inner capsule but at
three weeks on top on the top side of
the implants as well as the bottom we
took two different locations for each
you can see a much thicker capsule for
these larger textured or topography
surface implants
hours of six months the phenomena is
very similar again as i mentioned before
there's a little bit of thinning out of
the capsule in general because the
immune system starts to go away a little
bit at three weeks you see here 1500
thickness micron thickness and it's six
months here on the topsoil and plant
they're down to about a thousand it's
still the largest amongst the group
uh on the bottom setting planet it's
about a thousand here and
i would say between 500 and a thousand
after six months as well so a little bit
of thinning but across these implants
you see
uh double capsule especially in the two
larger sizes also with microsoft which
is not shown here seroma when you
actually open these implants up there's
a lot of liquid a lot of inflammation a
lot a lot of
immune response fibrosis scoring uh we
want just from the quantitation this is
obviously a qualitative presentation of
this and then contracture we saw ripple
lines as early as three weeks for the
control smooth and then more so with the
higher texture the higher topography
implants too all right so in the mice
uh
again we tried placing them in the
memory fat at the base of the belly at
first and then we realized was that the
skin is very taut there and it made it
difficult in terms of wound healing in
some cases so we ended up rotating the
implant on the back of the hip this was
a very early surgery attempt actually
with four one clips the the smaller
incision even in the mouse the less
chance for bacterial contamination and
complications but we i also later put
the incision higher up in a lateral
position and then we slid the implant
down right from the hip to make sure
again they were not overlapping
in all cases and uh and why was that
okay well in the mice interestingly with
all their mammary fat pads that start on
the belly side they actually wrap around
the back of the animal back of the neck
as well as in the front of the hip and
so when we place the breast implant here
it was believe it or not still sitting
in memory fat
and again so we're reiterating what he
said before implants were made with the
same manufacturing techniques so mold in
the case of the control smooth surface
um smooth silk excuse me velvet surface
poly polyurethane foam imprint here for
pu for polyurethane and uh and then the
salt loss here you can see
much larger
mixing crane is on the surface of his
implants and these are all actually
coming out of the animal after about
three weeks or so and you can even see
that that really large texture you get a
lot of aggregation of other biologic
molecules maybe blood and tissue and
some clotting factors
um all right so we monitored implants
many implants and mice over a long time
course
we did a full the full range of textures
for at least three and six weeks in some
cases twelve we did uh control though of
the traditional smooth versus
smooth silk hours of at least six months
and so when we when you resect the
tissue and you flip it over you see very
thick capsules for the traditional zero
micron smooth
uh very thick
real quick very thick capsules that form
it's nice and mice the tissue and the
implants being small you can actually
get most of this in one histology
cassette in one image and so there's the
top side of the skin with the fur
follicles here's the lower lying
musculature and then here's the caps on
the top sides it comes down into the
area that meets up with the lower lying
tissue fibrotic capsule also on the
bottom and this happens in human
patients you actually see these ripple
lines in this interspace where they
where they both meet
for the four micron surface just both
technically being qualified as smooth
implants just having slight topography
actually does something to make the
response very uniform and controlled
very thin almost translucent like
capsules in all cases and histologically
you see also similarly corresponding
very thin
uh very very thin
collagen deposition
actually when i quantify the thickness
of this on average it was about one
tenth of the thickness of the fibrotic
layer for the control smooth implants so
for the full range of implants you can
see very thick here for the zero micron
control smooth very thin the thinnest in
fact for all of them for the four micron
smooth smooth
silk um 15 micron velvet surface was a
little bit larger
30 micron close to celtex i guess and
rough average roughness is a little bit
thicker still and then the biocell life
90 micron salt loss technique very thick
capsules here but
it's starting to become on a more
similar scale is the control smooth some
very there's some variability here at
three weeks at six weeks where this data
matches you can see
that control smooth is not great
for micron surface ameliorated capsule
thickness formation to the greatest
extent and then obviously it's tighter
on the way back up is uh you start
achieving higher macro texture
texture status
all right so one of the things that we
did do initially uh trying to
understand the immune response is if we
ran multiplex and industry analysis and
there were two categories that popped up
one where smooth silk had gene
expression that was depressed and
inhibited or lower
and some of the things popped out very
clearly collagen 1a1 lower expression
makes sense less there's less fibrosis
cd68 lower macrophage response they're
associated with fibrosis uh less pres
lower presence in the capsules tnf alpha
less inflammation and so on and so forth
we saw the same thing in black six mice
here f4 80 and cd68 macrophage markers
also decreased
um and then there was another subtype of
of genes that increased with smooth cell
and the genes that increased were
actually associated with an
immuno-inhibitory phenotype fox p3
regulatory t suppressor cell marker is
here we also had amino inhibitory
cytokines l4 l10 l13 is an example and
the same thing in not only rabbits the
same thing was also observed uh fox p3
is here all four is here
same thing was observed in the mice i'll
tend this here and so on
all right now one of the problems with
this doing this type of analysis is this
is all rna coming from mixed tissue so
even though you might say this is a
specific immune marker like fox p3 it
should be for t-rex someone someone's
going to say well you didn't sort cells
and you didn't do single cell analysis
so how immunologically relevant is this
you don't really know for sure where
things are coming from so
went back to our old techniques in the
wheelhouse of dissociating tissues and
want one to get single cells for flow
cytometry analysis
and now with modern technologies
including thermo as a tune nxt system
including their their psychic max 96
volt plate auto sampler we're able to
not like earlier on allocated samples
into multiple tubes for only a few
antibodies in each we now can go upwards
of 14 different colors
very high combinatorial possibility our
particular build of our instrument is
violet blue yellow and red as opposed to
a green laser in the position of the
yellow
um we just felt that it had the highest
contour possibilities the most popular
fluorophores
and so we ended up
getting cd68 c11b innate myeloid cell
identity showing that they again
correlate heavily with the level of
fibrotic response that we were seeing
and in addition there was this
phenomenon or theory in the field that
uh fox p3t regs were important for
suppressing immune response
um
for micron surface was increased but so
were the other topographies the larger
topographies
and so we wanted to understand this more
so on the left this is absolute number
of cells
but on the right this is percent
composition
and i'm trying to differentiate between
the two because just because something
is lower percent if it's also like 10 10
fold less cells it's going to also be on
an absolute scale
a much more muted response
and uh before i show you we ended up
going to single cell rna-seq and
analysis also with the dissociative
tissues to really look at the phenotype
someone might also say well
compositionally they're the same
percentages
but
are these fox p3 t-rex really truly
inhibitory
probably maybe but it also depends on
the balance with other cell types like
cd8t cells and other more
pro-inflammatory phenotypes to determine
the overall net effect of the tissue
real quick first with the multi-color
panel we were using cd3 cd4 uh gated
into c25 and fox v3 so here is unstained
just background levels here's the
control smooth surface so you can see a
prominent c4 population and a very low
positive cd25 and fox b3 population
showing very low t-reg presence
confirming this this is where we got
these numbers from and then this is the
full micron surface had a a much larger
t-reg presence as as shown here uh
approximately about five or six volt
higher
all right but schematically again we
take the outer line capsule right around
the first implant associated we can
separate it not just for flow which i'm
going to show you more date on right now
but also for rna-seq so firstly at two
and four weeks we did this and we ran
much larger uh antibody panels all in
the same tube same sample just with
different fluorophores using the itunes
system
c3 positivity cd3 cd4 c25 fox p3 and so
again you see the confirmation of the
higher t-reg presence cd19 b cells seem
to be higher compositionally percentage
of cd45 in the 90 micron implant group
as well as where cd3 cd8 co-positive
effector set of toxic t-cells
uh same
observations at four weeks
when we when we
graphed the level of t regs over cda t
cells
we actually saw a higher
shift towards suppressive t regs in the
four micron group at both time points uh
and less so with with zero and the 90
micron groups fibroblast wise we we
didn't see too much significant
difference the percentage values were
very low we only attended we only saw a
little bit of an increase in 90 micron
group at a tubic time point using not
just alpha small muscle acting but also
copositivity for fibroblast activation
protein
all right so in addition to just cell
numbers though as i mentioned phenotype
is important
and so using principle component
analysis of single cell rna sequencing
data we determined we were able to
determine where neutrophils fell in this
plot macrophages monocytes andridic
cells t and k and b and b cells and so
comparing a couple of select genes as an
example so a transcription factor
involves an immune response cxcl10 which
is important for cell stress and
interfering gamma pro inflammation
cytokine you can see zero micron versus
four micron versus 90 micron and now you
start to see this really macro texture
group how much higher expression you're
getting in some cases especially here
for if you're in front gamma
falling in the in the tnk group
if you don't just look at three genes
and you look at everything we ran
uh zero isn't zero micron is set to the
baseline control at zero uh four micron
there's a there are definitely some
genes going up and some genes going down
we even stride it into all of these
different immune cell types again this
data is in the supplement of the paper
but with a 90 micron group especially
you have you have a much higher level of
many genes there's number of clusters of
genes here that are that are exacerbated
further and this is all this can also be
visualized by literally um looking at
the fall change differences between 90
and 4 and 90 has significantly higher
expression
as well as lower expression of a great
number of genes if you compare the four
micron surface to zero control
there aren't there aren't a significant
uh outlier group either up or down in
that case
all right so um so i'm sorry we're
starting to put these the picture
together in terms of single cell data
now
and then we want to look longer term so
four micron smooth silk surface
has the best inhibition
by what we think is t-reg induction
compared to traditional smooth so here's
the capsule thickness and again as i
mentioned earlier by about three months
or 12 weeks you can see the capsule
starts to shrink a little bit as some of
the immune system goes away some of the
inflammation volume goes away
but in the case of the four micron
smooth silk surface it's actually a very
active rather than passive inhibition
and it's maintained over a long period
of time
uh you can see cd68c live in b mirrors
what we're seeing in the fiber in terms
of the capsule thickness in both cases
significant levels of reduction that's
moves up with smooth silicon at all time
points and what's interesting is that
fox p3 the t-rex marker that we
highlighted earlier that i highlighted
earlier was significantly increased with
the four micron surface at all time
points outwards of even six months
again t-regs
are important for preventing
autoimmunity overreaching immune
response attacking your own tissues we
know about them maybe in the context of
cancer hijacking t-rex to shut down
killer t-cell response too but in the
context of what they do they can secrete
cytokines indirectly that are inhibitory
they can also affect macrophage subtype
differentiation in their from their
behavior they can even bind with
checkpoint inhibitor pathway molecules
such as ctla4
and so we hypothesize well t-rex are
truly important for the full micron
surface when we went into a t-cell
deficient variant of the black six model
so the nude nude variants
you can see that the capsule thickness
for the control smooth zero micron
surface didn't change much from wild
type response but the capsule for the
four micron implants dramatically
thickened
definitely definitely implicating t
cells in their active suppression of a
thick capsule capsule thickness now look
no no different uh in term compared to
the form
iv versus zero and macrophage response
also increased dramatically
statistically being no different as well
lastly i just want to show some human
data we're very proud of this so what
happens in humans you know again we want
to talk about generalizability of
findings from rodents into rabbits into
into obviously clinically relevant
patients and patient samples
so we're able to get ffpe hormone fixed
department embedded samples and and
perform histologic analysis to look at
the capsule thickness for control smooth
implants
uh smooth silk a very thin
pink layer here with blue you can see
there's almost like a line of
demarcation here biocell also had sort
of a line of separation a pink outer
ring even blew out a ring and so quantum
quantifying these uh using image j you
can see a statistical inhibition or
or reduction in capsule thickness with
the four micron smooth slope surface
and uh so establishment labs also
contributed these images but you can see
that in six months not much of a capsule
very thin even by 26 months in a patient
very thin layer
that they don't want to remove
and then after five years they literally
pulled out the capsule you can see how
thin and translucent it is actually if
you let it sit what we will be observing
is if you let it sit in the air for time
it'll start to uh dry up a little bit
and that's why it tends to have this
like kind of cracked like appearance to
it but it's very controlled and
maintained for long periods of time as
well from what we can tell
in many patients and and so we ended up
also performing the industry analysis
comparing four micron smooth silk seeing
a nice clustering of phenotype here
amongst many genes here's traditional
smooth in the middle showing a more
varied response a little bit but not too
different but still varied you can see
one sample here looks pretty distinct
and then there's some other blue popping
out in these groups and these individual
samples coming from these are from five
different individual human patients by
the way
and in the case of the 90 micron group
there was a very
distinct subset phenotype that popped
out in these samples as well
tying yet again surface topography and
average roughness and other features of
surface topography to host
biocompatibility and implant response
there's more data in the paper uh the
biosol implant has now been rescinded
off the market it was a voluntary recall
by the company after the fda recommended
it
when someone when they brush open those
cavities on the surface um
there's the possibility for micro
particle wear debris to shed off into
the shrunk tissue we actually saw it on
the rabbits too in the histology samples
little little pieces of polymer sitting
in the tissue uh larger surface area
though people looking also looking at
bacterial contamination and biofilm
formation and lastly just stability they
call tribology but the ability for a
much more textured implant to rub
against tissue and to literally scratch
and to damage the surrounding tissue to
a greater extent so i just want to say
thanks to the team at mit obviously our
mentor bob langer uh jenny and morgan in
the animal facility they're helpful with
many of the rapid procedures especially
our team at johns hopkins uh new phd
students in the lab that i started as of
2018
ami who was a fellow postdoc back at mit
is now professor rice mark clemens and
others at uh
md anderson in baylor
as part of that consortium in texas and
then the establishment labs motiva team
so uh dr schwarzer was a
a specialist who came in to show us that
uh imagine
insertion sleeve technique uh tren uh
implantation procedure was super cool uh
uh roberto um
leading scientific initiatives at the
company i think is cso officially
believe um
amazing uh feedback the company has been
very research for this whole time
because they generally care not only
about how their implants are working but
also how to make them better they want
to they want to help patients and they
want and they don't want
individuals to worry about these other
side effects that have happened in the
past
the team at establishment labs the
material science and research team also
for development of the miniature
implants for too many people to name
individually and the ceo one was a also
amazing the patient forward comes from a
family of surgeons who care very deeply
about patient health as well and
obviously all of the players in this
consortium
so without further ado happy to take any
questions you have
uh and thanks for thanks for listening
thank you dr doloff for your informative
princess date presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
in our first question is
many have wondered is it just the
surface directly
or secondary effects of bacteria biofilm
colonization
tri biology
tissue movement and friction
and or surface particle wear debris can
you discuss these potentially
contributing factors and what is the
popular thought in the field right now
as to which may have a larger
contribution to host rejection response
thanks for the excellent question um and
and marie and michelle and the others
for the invitation again um
it's a complicated area of the field
right now i think there's a lot of
evidence to show that the more pock
marked the surfaces
there is the potential for higher
literally higher surface area and sort
of these nooks and crannies where
bacteria can
seed
settle and create biofilm we know that
in the field of fibrosis
when biofilms or bacteria are present
they do exacerbate inflammation and that
does feed forward into fibrotic response
but from what we've seen here so the
data from this paper and from the
presentation that you saw today
it was heavily focused on techniques
that were completely were done in this
sterile manner if possible as possible
we actually eliminated one rabbit for
instance that
was scratching at its incision suture
line it did become infected with
bacteria and we ended up excluding the
animal completely and had to replace it
with another another procedure
uh so we really in this particular case
what's interesting is that you know we
have the ability to synchronize
everything same surgical technique same
sterile everything pre-sterilized
um
we there were no there's no variation
from clinic to clinic or from surgical
technique or surgeon technique to
surgeon
um
and so what we were trying to do at
least is regardless of the stimuli that
makes host rejection worse which yes it
can be in theory bacteria's presence we
tried to at least
ensure that that did not happen here
where particle debris there's a lot of
evidence to show that
you know due to that earlier process of
frustrated phagocytosis immune cells
can't eat up particles
so they then swarm around the surface
and it maintains a long-term chronic
inflammation response rather than a
short-term acute one
and then even and so that obviously can
play a role um and then we also
we also interestingly had a lot of
conversations with plastic surgeons and
even with patients talking about
lifestyle choices like if you
were a heavier patient or you were more
muscular or and you were physically
active versus not so physically active
did you like to skydive did you like to
go deep sea diving you know so exertion
of pressure on the implant or on your
body the ability for more abrasion and
movement
where the implant surface could rub
against
nearby tissue so that's what we call
tribology so the friction the frictional
components of it
and the abrasion and stressing of those
cells and so on so it's
there's the possibility that all of them
are involved to some degree i think
right as of right now for this
particular data set what i think is
clear is that we see
direct cert direct effects of the
surface outright clearly uh from just
from just a titered surface topography
um i think as a next step we're very
interested in you know spiking in
bacteria in a controlled manner across
the board maybe also
um you know there's a lot of i think
there are groups for instance there's
the center for biofilm engineering and
montana state there's other there's
other groups around the country that are
actively doing some of these other types
of studies in vitro
you know i think the tricky thing
sometimes though is that when you're
working in a cell culture dish how do
you properly
recapitulate all the movement right how
do you use a cheesecloth do you use a
different type of biomaterial on the
surface that's that's literally
laterally moving back and forth to try
to scrat scrape away or brush away some
of the
implant shell topography
um
they're the techniques being used are
much better than what they than with
where they were originally in the field
but uh
if you were gonna if you wanted to ask
my firm opinion based on the data that
we saw we see we definitely had real
real-time evidence of particulate debris
in the surrounding shells for at least
the the large range
um the highest micro and macro textured
implants not further not for the rest
and so that there was clear evidence
even just from the rabbit model
that that was potentially playing a role
in the host rejection response we were
seeing now you know there's this crazy
um
excision plan that
that was released by the company that
was originally selling by a cell it was
like a 14 point plan that said if you
follow every one of these steps you can
remove the entire fibrotic tissue
capsule around the biocell implant group
and then reduce or eliminate the risk of
of hopefully what they later saw to be
there was actually a lymphocytic a
breast implant associated with lymphoma
that was forming in some very minut
wedge of patients
but it was uh it was risky
which was shown to be risky which is why
the fda requested from the company to do
a volunteer recall and they ultimately
did
um and thankfully that particular
topography was not used heavily in the
us although it has been used worldwide
in other contexts
so yeah it's a complicated field i think
more investigation needs to be done but
uh
we're already seeing some evidence that
it's at least one if not multiple of
those factors for sure
thank you dr doloff do you have any
final comments for our audience
um you know i think the crazy thing with
all this work really also from seeing
the perspective of you know plastic
surgeons sometimes that you know it's
amazing they
were really resistant to change surgical
techniques in the field you know it's
like they learn from their grandmaster
mentor like you know what jedi master
did they learn these things from and
eventually got to a place where if your
failure rate as a clinical surgeon was
worse significantly worse than the
average failure rate in the hospital
you know you wouldn't get your annual
bonus or it would affect your reputation
with patients right so they would
obviously at that point be behooven
they'd be moved to consider another
alternative solution
um
and now that it's crazy but now we're
finally seeing these interes this
interesting tighter four micron surface
or the four micron average roughness
surface smooth silk that
is has an active effect
and i think surgeons are now having to
consider well okay well if there's a
technology now that dramatically
improves success
or the rate of success
they have to consider it at least for
themselves from that perspective but you
know really realistically just getting
the data out there and we had a lot of
conversations about this too because the
the
story went to a nature journal which
plastic surgeons don't typically read
they usually look at the journal plastic
surgery let's say and so we were
wondering do we do another follow-up
sort of release in more plastic surgery
journals but the reality was to us at
least is what we discovered from
speaking with patients and doctors is
that most breast implant patients are
quite differential to their surgeons and
the clinicians that they work with
we just wanted to get this information
out there so that the patients
themselves hopefully
in concert with their doctor can make
the most informed choice about the risks
the risk the potential risks and their
own personal health
involved as well um
and and maybe they'll feel like this
seems like the at least in terms of the
topography the range of rough the
roughness ranges or texturing in general
for the met for the larger ranges of
texture
um
you know it's a simple enough concept
for
anyone to come into a clinic's office
like a clinician's office and to be able
to discuss this at a basic level
and it's approachable right it gives
them a basis for having a discussion and
saying well does this make sense or
doesn't it and
you know it's amazing too doctors in the
past lastly the last point i'll make is
um
doctors in the past just for needs of
symmetry you know in most cases
obviously there's definitely
augmentation cases but we
are looking actually the next step also
hopefully patients uh cancer patients
who've had double mastectomies and
reconstruction
and um you know in some cases a doctor
would either put a different volume
implant on the left versus the right
side if there's some asymmetry or if
maybe even the the bone plate like the
sternum and the chest plate is not
perfectly symmetrical in terms of how
it's angled
um but some cases they would also place
in two different implants one with one
surface topography on the left and one
with a different surface topography on
the right
and uh
and does it and interestingly because of
that
you found it from the company that they
don't ever they sell units as individual
units they don't actually sell them as
left and right pairs for that reason
because it's a lot of clinicians don't
want to buy them as parrot implants
because they won't have the flexibility
so
it's weird thinking about these things
from a market perspective and a personal
health perspective but we sometimes need
to on the research side as well
um
and i guess it just got us to a place
where
at least now there's information where
more information where a patient feels
maybe more empowered to make personal
health decisions you know for the long
term
yeah but i guess that's it and uh if
there's any more questions i'm happy to
obviously feel them later remotely uh if
the thermo team sends them to me
otherwise thanks for listening really
appreciate it
well thank you again dr doloff for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting question
uh questions if you have questions that
you needed to submit or think of at a
later time
um
please do so and they will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye